estamos clasificando figuras geométricas
reconociendo los tipos de triángulos
aquí dice clasifican los siguientes
triángulos como escaleno o isósceles
seleccionando la categoría apropiada
entonces bueno un triángulo escaleno es
un triángulo cuyos lados todos son
distintos y un triángulo isósceles es un
triángulo que tiene dos lados iguales
entonces bueno veamos este primer
triángulo este primer triángulo tiene
todos los lados que miden ocho entonces
es equilátero pero bueno un isósceles
tiene dos lados iguales así que un
triángulo equilátero es un triángulo
isósceles entonces este es isósceles
veamos ahora este este triángulo tiene
dos lados iguales y uno distinto
entonces es también isósceles ahora éste
tiene un lado que mide 3 otro que mide 5
y otro que mide 4 entonces bueno como
todos sus lados miden distinto
es un escaleno ahora este último
triángulo veamos uno un lado mide ocho
otro nueve y otro 10 entonces como todos
sus lados miden distinto entonces es
escaleno vamos a comprobar la respuesta
perfecto siguiente pregunta
dice cuáles de los siguientes son
descripciones correctas del triángulo o
v w x elige todas las opciones correctas
el triángulo no tiene lados o iguales
bueno veamos si tiene lados iguales de
hecho todos los lados son iguales aquí
lo podemos ver todos lados mil 888
entonces esto no no es correcto el
triángulo o w ls equilátero sí porque
todos lados miden lo mismo 8 8 y 8
entonces esta es una opción correcta
el triángulo tiene un ángulo obtuso un
ángulo obtuso es un ángulo que mide más
de 90 grados y el triángulo o w l tiene
ángulos que miden menos de 90 grados
todos sus ángulos miden menos de 90
grados no tiene ángulos obtusos
el triángulo tiene tres ángulos agudos
un ángulo agudo es un ángulo que mide
menos de 90 grados y como todos sus
ángulos que son 3 porque es un triángulo
miden menos de 90
entonces si tiene tres ángulos agudos
el triángulo o w l tiene un ángulo recto
y un ángulo recto mide exactamente 90
grados aquí no haya ningún aquí no hay
un ángulo de 90 grados entonces bueno
eso es incorrecto vamos a comprobar la
respuesta
hagamos uno más
cuáles de los siguientes tipos de
triángulos describen al triángulo x y ez
dice elige todas las opciones correctas
veamos
este triángulo es un triángulo agudo
bueno pues sí porque tiene todos sus
ángulos aquí vemos que miden menos de 90
grados
entonces si si lo describe obtuso
un triángulo obtuso no porque no tiene
un ángulo que mida más de 90 grados
recto bueno no porque no tiene ningún
ángulo que mida 90 grados equilátero sí
porque todos lados miden lo mismo 10 10
entonces bueno isósceles y socio desde
entonces tiene o debe tener dos lados
que miran lo mismo como tiene tres lados
que miden lo mismo entonces tiene dos
lados que mide lo mismo también entonces
es isósceles y escaleno es un triángulo
cuyos lados todos son distintos entonces
no no es escaleno comprueba tu respuesta
perfecto